welcome to this video playing Grand
Master Dominator who the heck is that no
name ok it's not exactly the most
dominating opening ever but it's not bad
of course the the four night Scotch four
nights very safe opening h3y Ellis's
chrome next line maybe just h6 I really
never bothered to study that I mean it's
not bad for a white or anything it's
just that it always feels like if you're
black you've got more serious things to
consider but anyway yeah White's plays
certainly easy sorry for the drinking
noises just need some some beverage em
oh I didn't think about that at all I
should pay more attention that's not
good this is not that good him
I mean you're not going to I'm going to
get the checkmated quickly or anything
but it'sit's kind of this annoying slide
pool that white has it makes this quite
problematic yeah maybe something like
this I don't know it's maybe a bit be
too too simple all rights going he's
going to get cheap fire laughs I mean
it's really not a lot of Nazi five
rookie aid
hmm check and the Scotch four nights is
really one of the most boring openings
that white can play but it is really
okay and this is here definitely better
for why this position and I said it's
not it's not much but it is there this
advantage 97 has also stuff like 23
being very annoying a 5 hmm a 5 is not
really clear that it helps me at all
come on let's do that king of eight I
think I should be okay if he trades
everything off he has a four a five but
I'm quick with the king
but I don't believe that it's so great
so what about this ok once queen d 6
it's a nice and nice ID n cream be a
does not playable ha interesting move
maybe this one why am I don't cry my
screwing things up terribly here ok
maybe I cannot see I cannot invest much
more time now
okay if we go back
yeah it's not very fun to play this you
can also just play I don't know c3 or
something or a three and continues to be
annoying check okay and that I don't
believe in I mean in terms of playing
for win for white my king is this just
to act of him what am I missing here
really am I not just better here
jinx I mean sorry G for Bishop c6 chick
nah not even doing that i can go Bishop
f4 is is even stronger yeah and here i
have c 3 or let's be precise i can also
go King b5 simply threaten you to cover
that and then take the pawn why is there
something better if i go c 3 and Bishop
be fine I'm and winning or not yeah this
is also pretty pretty convincing
actually
it's maybe not so I mean how do I hey
it's got that located maybe this was a
mistake huh allowing this business maybe
that was a mistake don't really see how
I'm winning now
that's probably a draw that's bad after
after this game well our third game draw
ciao I was stupid that it was bad bad
play bet that technical play by me i
should just win this of course i think
it's probably pretty simple my computer
makes the same mistake playing we should
be five okay that's probably not a
mistake yet but it's not not not really
precise but how do I win actually Jeff I
go here he goes back not sure let this
does win what about this then a 6-pin
also annoying okay I'm everyone dies
there's still some way to win g5
can have some more enter them that the
engine does this have six txtx is 16 b 6
yeah this thing I guess I get to play
this and now the bishop is really boxed
in but I cannot if I go like this then
he always just I'm sorry it goes to d2
and draws there's no soup spot i think
but i can go over here over here
probably and he cannot prevent king edge
5 so this is the wind okay and so then
this is probably probably screwing it up
now the computer still gives black a
winning advantage which is wrong I think
this is just a draw I really don't see
how i'm entering you this is not going
to happen I think this is really just a
draw hmm that's disappointing okay
thanks for watching